hello and welcome to Westeros weekly
what hi I'm Sol Molina and this
hi I'm Lloyd Garret Maude Garrett and
we're going to do a kind of breakdown of
what happened this week specifically
using our wonderful mat back here to
help you kind of really grasp where
everyone is and why that matter and
mostly we're just gonna be answering the
questions that you guys had about this
episode you guys use the hashtag
Westeros weekly will answer a bunch of
those here and other ones will be in our
breakdown which by the way again this
does not replace the breakdown and doing
more content even more bonus content and
the breakdown will have answers to other
questions
so let's get back enjoyed this is the
season 7 episode 2 called storm board
and apologies to my voice I was at Comic
Con all weekend too busy partying with
Samwell Tarly look at this picture ok
yeah we're super tight now you tell me
everything and no so let's check out
this map obviously we always check in
with this particular map to see where
everyone is and what kind of movements
we've had with everyone in the shot the
major players we saw this week at
Winterfell
we've got Sansa and Littlefinger and
everybody's favorite little bear oh yeah
and a couple of other people too but we
actually had the exodus of the white
wool mmm mr. Jon Snow he's on his way to
meet with Danny Targaryen back at what's
happening yeah second Jamie waits a
little NART saying hey step on by I wait
to be pals in season 1 don't you
remember that I like that they're both
just like that Bros a good guy yes
horrible people what I didn't notice the
tyrion did miss a key detail in that
nartz then come down to meet Jenny and
Bethany did not say that in the note
yeah so we have them at white Harbor
because that's where they'll be taking
off from we haven't seen them actually
get on a boat yet a little further south
of that that's where ru is we're going
to get really into this idea of which
direction our is headed a she had a
purpose but there's been a bit of a I
wanna side against better in the works
because I've learned that now yeah so
we'll check in with her a little later
and then here is where we got a lot of
movement so we had to split some forces
up so we have on the Far West of
Westeros at Castle Rock we do know there
are Lannister forces there but Jamie and
Cersei of course are still like King's
Landing and then we also split up the
Targaryen force because they are about
to take the movement so we've got
Daenerys Targaryen and
Tyrion and Varys and her main people
still at Dragonstone but just alongside
them we have the unsullied who are
preparing to go on a mission of their
own to also get to and then just south
of that we know that some amazing crazy
naval stuff happened and we'll get to
that too yep but we have specifically
this digital here that I'll zoom in on
just a little bit more specifically the
normal Greyjoy one and a regular
normal-sized Kraken a Kraken and then
it's like it's like a pine a little bit
of a red mark there so the red is
specific to you're on Greyjoy so it's a
nice way to be able to keep track
especially in that naval battle I think
it needs that blood on anything I hope
so because otherwise this weird red spot
the crack which was weird and then going
a little to the southwest
we know that the tyrell forces are still
near Highgarden we believe Olin is on
her way to get them we'll get to that
too and then a little to the southeast
of the Tyrells are the Tarly forces did
what Lord Charlie is about to go again
it's going to be a major player in the
upcoming war so that's why we actually
added them to the mass yeah and then to
the lower southwest of him we've got his
son who is not a major player in the
greater Wars but could be depending on
what happens it could take a whole lot
of problems here Sam oh really yes I do
we're talking about because I we don't
often see the Tolly sigil and I think
it's really interesting to note that it
is arches that's going to come into play
bringing it back to that and then at the
far tip of Dorne at Sunspear or the
Dornish forces to be clear the Dornish
forces did not include a lot of sand and
the sand snakes but let's get to mystic
lis your guys's question this show is
all about your question so every single
week we do ask that you jump onto
Twitter as soon as you've seen the
episode because we like to watch it as
soon as it's out as well using a hashtag
Westeros weekly and put some questions
on us and we can answer for you and then
your questions could also make it into
the breakdown of course later in the
week so these are just questions you
guys had in general that we thought we'd
hit up up first of all what's the deal
with what's going on by the wall let's
deal with the wall so notice very
specifically here this is the wall that
we're looking at yeah we're really
talking about the water right off here
to the side and this is from season six
is just lost season but because when she
is now here there is a huge
change but it's sort of terrain change
could mean a big plot change as well
the water has frozen over to the east of
the wall inside we have a red circle
yeah this is new rocks if we don't get a
red throwing things wrong how would you
know what we're going to think about is
not a red circle and a arrow yeah where
do I look in this escalator but big deal
is the wool is obviously there to stop
people from going through it or past it
but now that's almost redundant with an
extension of mine over water
many of the undead army can just walk
right on through that is insane
they could there's no there's no need to
bring down the wall when you can just go
around it what chemistry says a really
good job of is subtle hints and it's
happened this episode but last episode
it was the subtle hints but they kept
saying the wall is impenetrable
the wall has stopped all bad things from
coming through there forever the wall is
what going to save us oh the walls
impenetrable what does they go around it
oh yeah you know what summer people
think they don't think of the real
friend I've never had this much wind up
some normally just weather obviously but
I mean like for generations if you look
at a Gon's map table we got really great
shots of it coming later but we got him
through this episode the north is lush
and green yet he was there in true
summer so really this isn't something
that they have thought of anytime weekly
but here's my thing everyone's asking
can the White Walkers take this path I'm
going to say it looks like it but I
think not yet because I watched a little
bit further down and this is another
kind of overhead view and if you see
it's not super solid yet that's why they
waiting they've got all the time in the
world it's just taken six seasons to get
it to that so I think we're like right
to like it could be fun if they like
surf in on like you know shaky iceberg
this idea of going around the walls like
the stupidest thing I've ever heard of
that makes perfect time yeah next
question this was asked by like 35
people what is the deal with the stag
sigil on King's Landing yeah so if we
zoom in you can actually see that it
still supposedly is a stronghold of the
Baratheon so we actually haven't had a
Baratheon since Robert himself and he
never
produced any actual is you had a lot of
bastards one of them we still don't know
where he's going
shout out to Gendry one time but in this
particular case there are only
Lannisters though it only last is on the
throne mercy is now I mean [ __ ] that we
don't overcorrect in so we're thinking
of the sigil being kind of like almost
like a legal status yes right and it's
like well you're a widow of the
Baratheon family so then you would think
okay so then the map that we see at the
beginning of the show is just objective
yeah
subjective it's not what she feels like
she is she may have put Lannister things
everywhere but it's technically still a
Baratheon hold because otherwise she
would have no claim so that introduces a
complication because if the law of the
land says well you were married to a
Baratheon so this is belong so Baratheon
well then what the hell do you say about
Sansa Stark being the last stark in
Winterfell right now he's been married a
couple of times yeah I believe so that
belonged to the Lannisters because she
was married to Tyrion so then he was
like denounced as a Lannister altogether
as well so maybe battle could my desk on
so then does it belong to the Bolton
still she's a widow yeah she literally
becoming thirty more and more well and
she's power-hungry she's in the north
she's got the power now and oh so I'll
be honest I think that this either needs
to change or it means that some serious
stuff is going to happen up north
it's kind of funny as well though
because like if you go back to last
season when I do get the stars in they
kind of unveiled the fact that you did
have illegitimate children and the whole
of King's Landing knew about it because
i were talking about the blond-haired
children one of my favorite things is
that everyone around not to keep any but
Westeros talks about the game of Thrones
like they're watching the TV show your
Cersei has like all these kids right but
also and he's like oh your brother won
the battle of the bastard yeah that we
call it recently named the episode
movement but for them it's like football
it's like all it's the Bolton's versus
the stocks because one team died I know
that every single episode we do a Power
Poll basically who's in the best
position I actually think you guys vote
on by the way and what are the results
at the end of the episode
hot pie is in technically and
logistically the best addition because
he's at the crossroads he hears all the
information spurt
he is just an abundance of knowledge
which is probably why he looks full of
informational here he's been making lots
of pies and how do you get good at
making pies you eat a lot of pie I
didn't say it directly and you did with
your eyes and earlier in a text message
all right I'm just so glad he's back
yeah I know he divided up yeah but
didn't this kind of feel like she was
gonna be like no so the bastard colors
question hey speaking of schedules that
we had earlier that are confusing the
opening credits hey you guys noticed
that this is a white bull so some of you
are asking why did it suddenly go from
gray to white as it did before
bastard I hate using that word so
liberally by the way but it's a
technical term and because of the
technical designation for a child they
actually have a different signal it's
the inverted colors so instead of the
white background with a werewolf
it's a white wolf on a grey background
is it symbolic that he actually does
have a white wolf ghost Wow a permit is
that so they refer to John as the white
wolf and his direwolf way to get some
guys actual man ghost always just shows
up right when he needed right hi so
those are the general questions but now
let's check in with some specific
characters that you guys had questions
about especially what they have going on
this week we're going to start with our
homeboy who is doing everything you can
to make us cuke every episode and that's
mr. Samwell Tarly
I feel like he's not doing dirty jobs
for a living right now yeah but the
question that you guys actually had was
about the other moment that Sam
experiences and that's when he's dealing
with the maester in the library and his
poor guys like you know I mean maesters
like my day job but I'm actually working
on a novel and he's writing blood Kong
yeah I recognize he's writing about the
wars that took place after the death of
King Robert Baratheon which hey that
should be real familiar to you because
that's the plot of this series that
you've been watching for seven seasons
uh and of course there's that awesome
moment where you when you tell someone
something you're excited about and
they're like hi yeah I know okay but
what if you did this I've experienced a
lot thank you like basically writing a
book about
the game leading ups if he's going to be
on the throne yeah maybe that with me
and you called it the wars after the
death of King Robert present okay I just
think there's a better name so a lot of
you guys are asking oh is the name
ultimately going to be a song of ice and
fire or a game of throne and we'll say
sure it could be either of those I mean
I think we're on the same page with the
fact that Sam Holley kind of is playing
george RR martin when you think about it
he's your son he's the guy that never
really had a chance his father didn't
love him he didn't sit in when it came
to war he wasn't the one that was going
to bust out the sword and be a warrior
and when you really put them
side-by-side like this you can see the
similarities first of all the theory is
that george RR martin has placed himself
into the story in the character of
soundwalk harley the person who is
potentially going to be the one that
writes the story here's this really if I
actually love this theory we brought it
up about a year ago I did in our old
breakdown boom and what I love about it
now that it's happening I'm seeing how
it could happen I have like so excited
for it and I'm realizing Sam stole that
guy's book idea oh yeah the guy was
having Sam is probably gonna be like you
know I had an idea for a book oh my gosh
George Arad mental he's probably like
past like turning his grave being like
you're making how much money for my idea
you can picture yourself a song device
can fire a game of Thrones or the wars
that took place after king Bret I mean
the books are flying off of these also
yeah the next question we got was about
thirsty a little check in with Cersei
and Jaime again they are at King's
Landing but very specifically a lot of
people are talking about this scene
where Cersei is just dropping a bunch of
fake news about what Daenerys Targaryen
been up to we talk about what everyone
brings to the table with Spanish
knowledge which equals power in the end
with Rosie it's propaganda she's using
actual events that have happened like
killing the slave masters which I happen
they did she did feed one of her dragons
as one of them but she did imply a lot
of that I think her use of propaganda is
a really smart thing to do but
specifically what you guys are asking
about is why are they so into this old
guy
mmm what does house Tarly bring to the
table well their reputation
which he keeps running his fun fan is
that they're brave they are always first
in battle they are loyal people as well
and they have like a really good
established army and they have been
playing by the rules basically this
whole time and very much else I have
this amazing fortress at horn Hill look
at that like if you guys remember when
they visited there last days and it was
kind of like damn this is nice
yeah we've been to castles but how
councils called Castle black like this
is like and it really does hump pain
that he sent his son away from a tree
was not good enough to be a Tarly right
so not only is horn Hill a very
important stronghold but also focusing
on what the tarly's have is a strong
sense of xenophobia ya know this is the
only time I'd really seen randyll Tarly
beforehand and we got a really clear
picture that he's not a nice person he
doesn't like wildlings at all he gave
Gilly a lot of trouble when he brought
in when fam brought her into the house I
think honestly he didn't show it but her
argument nailed it where it's like am I
really gonna stand by while a bunch of
horseback savages attack the land that I
you know kind of love yeah he's kind of
the honestly like the typical I don't
say all right for like the guy was like
he's got a shotgun on his land and
honestly if you've seen Red Dawn those
are the people that try to save us so
yeah he seems like that kind of person
also there was a moment that we kind of
heard echoed here Jaime but previously
Stannis Baratheon has recanted - Samwell
how his father Lord Randall's Harley
defeated Robert freakin Baratheon in the
Battle of Ashford the thing with that is
that Robert beat Rhaegar Targaryen yet
considered like the vampire God Ned find
battles
yeah and just Warhammer Dhin right
randyll Tarly defeated Robert Baratheon
on the battlefield the only reason that
Roberts survived is because they
retreated as quickly as they could
and so everyone considers guy just is
amazing soldier but something you hit on
earlier about their sigil is why I think
that they're going to play a big role in
the next season
yeah digital obviously being that of
arches and very specifically an army
full of archers who are experts at
aiming these things might be experts at
aiming one big huge one at one day huge
dragon because there's a big difference
between shooting it at a very very
ancient skull that is very
20 feet away yeah than one in flat I
don't want to see dragons die I you have
the rights are happening kidding me it's
three dragons one gonna die at least I
put money on it I know I have a theory
that two are gonna die that's even worse
than one and one is gonna die north of
the wall and then something bad will
happen to them they're like this yeah oh
no I don't have a nice cane you look
really good on it like a nice dragon oh
my god
man I just think of dragons like puppies
kind of and so I just I just feel real
bad a local boy near there good boy
we haven't any mess-ups at all because
we had a direwolf so let's take it to
the Seas at this time last time I heard
about your on he left King's Landing
things sweetheart I'm gonna get you a
gift we tried to predict what that gift
would be now it isn't clearer than ever
so last week I know it seemed like
Cersei wasn't really into whatever his
gift would be him annoying around with
game yeah she's pretty manipulation at
she's the worst but now you guys are
asking is is she going to change her
mind when she sees this gift has he won
her over now and I'm gonna say she was
unimpressed then but this guy's pretty
freaking impressive oh my gosh did
anyone else hear like WWE news it comes
yes plan through slid down it it's like
come on mate uh it was the coolest
entrance in the history of Game of
Thrones but the most ridiculous one that
the things it's so clear what they're
trying to do to him they're trying to
make him this season's antagonist
they're trying to make sure that
everyone hates him for all the right
reasons but he was also wanting to play
up to surf Eve cruelty she's getting a
reputation entirely touched on it before
going I know what happens when people
don't call to the Queen fan saw and he
knows that she's just a pretty horrific
person so how do you play someone that
terrific you match their cruelty and
he's bringing bags of heads and
knowledge and it's not just her cruelty
I think he's trying to match it's her
level of insanity and her loss of her
advantage yeah and having fun while
doing it I keep pushing that this guy's
a joker I think this is Harley Quinn
yeah and I think yes the answer to your
question is she's going to be like damn
man like you had a weird rock star thing
that was like kinda into but like now
like you're legit and also like even
though last episode so she tried to
really dust her emotions under the rug
saying look my children are dead I'm
here to move on how good would it be if
ilaria stands is presented to him along
with her favorite child
like this is revenge at a diner she's
going to make a ilaria kill her favorite
daughter maybe well maybe we know that
Dana and I are the closest of all those
sand snakes and their mother because
they outside that scene where she kept
talking about mama mama need to make fun
of her for that and those are the two
that he's going to apparently be
delivering we don't know if yare is
going to be part of that package we
don't know she looked like she was going
to die it didn't happen very nurturing
him just a road smile but many times as
I want to just really kind of shout
about the reaction of a lot of fans
watching the show and that was an
universal groan when the sand snakes
came back into this and then it was
almost as if the producers and the
riders went you know what we know you
hate them here is this satisfying enough
the answer is yes thank you very much it
felt like that last shot where their
bodies were like but it was for the fans
and about how they were strung up they
were strung up by their own weapon so
obviously you know through the spear
like the fish was stabbed skewered into
the ship and the other one was hanging
by her own whip that is like a little on
Lamar it seems a little bit like what
happened with Nikki and Paulo back on
lost where was like oh you guys don't
like them so we're gonna really hurt
them another question that you guys had
though is okay how the hell did he sneak
up on them and we got this graphic up
here because I am going to point out
first of all it was really foggy yeah in
fact it was like storm in the area not
too far away from there right I feel
like you know I don't see a threat
happening so they've dropped their
guards and they're about to get
hanky-panky literally right there
they're dropping it off when expecting
the other kind of foreign invasion right
which even though you're making that a
joke I think that that's that going in
there like and we were going to say
foreign invasion because it's like her
hands but also like they're about to be
killed
yeah yeah yeah very on the nose yeah I
love I love it yeah
but okay so we don't just think it was
fog I'm also going to say of course you
got to remember that just at this time
and with this technology don't make a
ton of noise as a go I think though they
very specifically there's main tactic is
actually not attracting light pollution
so they take out all their candles but
it feels like there actually could be
even better reason how not only they
were able to sneak up on them but know
the exact ships and the exact location
time that they would be there - is there
a snitch inside of Danny's camp now that
concept actually came up Danny she did
kind of like very suddenly get this idea
that wait now that I'm here in Westeros
everyone might not have my back she took
it out on Barris she challenged his
loyalty and got the best monologue from
varus's character we have seen thus far
and he gets some doozy moments in there
as well but doesn't it feel good Rangers
so transparent apparently I don't you
want he wants and she's clearly said I
do not want to be surrounded by yes-man
I want you to look me in the face and
tell me if I'm not doing a good job and
he's like yes I swear to that right but
you're right in this particular show
there is subtle or sometimes not so
subtle setups to these particular things
and if she's trying to weed out the rat
all the dividers in this case there
could be someone and he's never really
had particular loyalties he said it's
always been Targaryen but what if you
have to do to remain on rubber Baratheon
good side he's a survivor anything is
for the people right what about even me
right and I'll say if you are still
manipulator you're also going to appeal
to your audience so notice how he talks
a lot about having been a slave and how
both Masson day and grey worm are taking
extra note of that but also he's saying
that to Daenerys who has clearly such
sympathy for slaves is the breaker of
chains all right yeah so can we trust
Varys I don't think yes honestly I'm
going to fall for it
all the way if he's a double agent here
but it doesn't mean that someone else
isn't so let's talk through that because
he's technically the only one that
doesn't have a family that's been good
options right yeah cheering it's not
going to be Tyrion because he hates the
Lannisters and is not going to basically
make sure that Cersei wins in the game
of Thrones at all you've got Elena's
Tyrell whose granddaughter and grandson
were just killed by Cersei so there's no
way she's running out and then who else
is in that room there's
day and go no there you get my father
and if there's no way she would rat out
but my queen I've been plotting against
these all thing yeah it doesn't sound
like it would happen
that said not not totally going on down
this path but an interpreter is someone
who is always in the room at all the key
moments and can manipulate the
information coming in and out that is
true all right and our next question
that we're going to go to is about ooh
the poor Greyjoy's Theon and Yara and oh
man they had they suffered so bad at a
moment where they were just so happy at
least their ever conference was their
weakness yeah
and in this particular instance you've
got your own challenging feel on like
step up what amazing acting by Alfie
Allen because you can see him
transformed back into reek it was just
pathetic
and you kind of like responds well to
abusive people to tell them what to do
right another thing since there was no
way to win right a lot of people were
very mad at be on for what he does here
it looks cowardly it is cowardly but
also he is reek once again yeah I think
and this just sums up my head here so
maybe this won't work out but just
thinking of this idea of you know
deficit was called Stormborn and he
keeps having these traumatic experiences
and he comes out a different way and if
you remember back to leaping off the
wall yeah right and then on the other
side of that it felt like he had killed
reek and was reborn
yah-yah-yah now I think this little nope
moment is the opposite he's reborn as
reek at the same time I think that is
probably the best case scenario for him
potentially because this is what you
guys want to know and I'm wondering -
where does he go now who will take on
brief I have no idea everyone's joking
that is going to pick up Oh gendry's in
a row past and pick them up which I
would actually love I think that is a
great thing because he's been rolling
for for three or four seasons now his
arms must be like guns you've ever take
on the mountain that yeah where else is
he going to go I'm really I'm really
reaching here my
my one guess is if he is like you know
what I'm not iron born I never was I
pretended to be but that's not me you
know who I really am I was raised by the
Starks I'm gonna go back to Winterfell
and see if they'll take me back in may
be specifically sponsors there and they
just had a good moment to that's my
guest guys but let us know if you have a
better idea
he needs to serve a bigger purpose than
what he is currently yeah and I think
that purpose is going to end in his
death spider by probably so up next we
got you guys had a little
tongue-in-cheek question about our mr.
grey worm woman this is a long build-up
though because he's been craving on her
while she's been bathing so of course
you know obviously he hasn't got a hot
on flora but he's got something going on
I really think that mod wrote the
question this week which the question
was I thought Kraven didn't have a worm
that's a great question chuckle invite
both gone they get castrated well
wonderful another yes they lose both of
them so it's done he's not the only
eunuch
the other one is Varys embarrass lost
his testicles yeah I'm Theon's lost his
soft sausage um I'm trying to be
delicate about it well you saw her
testicles when you went back to Foster's
yes well could've that saying that we'll
never forget
our grandbaby mmm oh yeah along with the
pie and the body like the person the
pineapple soup mm anyway and they were
saying how does it really work
uh well good thing is we got 10 minutes
of this scene to realize he's going to
go down and eat it like a vulture that
is a missy elliot lyric is not suspect
she's a Kotra I love you guys to my wife
all right I had need a glass of water
there you go these are a lot of her but
you didn't see that part of him I was
saying to my roommate so I was watching
this do you think they put a green sock
over it to like fix it in post
I had such a stupid idea some part of my
brain was like maybe they can reveal
that he tucked it away the whole time
he's got one and he doesn't meet that
one no but he has a big heart and that's
what she's a total [ __ ] and I'll use
that without real were to speed over
right at the end work with borderline
pornographic slow but I do think that
the purpose of that and the length of
this scene and showing as much as they
did was to say there is a future that
could potentially involve romance for
this guy yeah and that honestly even
though it's you know might have been a
bit uncomfortable for something I
thought it was kind of sweet to just be
like no it's not awkward it's when two
people really care about each other
they're gonna find a way yes sure I also
do a hash tag for every episode and this
week is hash tag nub rub to be stung
with their nut nut song from the Ewoks
in doors oh man
rap don't watch this in school day
alright so our next question is also
related to the Targaryen force but it's
specifically about what's going on with
Danny and this is a very technical
question I do get why there was some
confusion here so we're going to walk
through you guys are wondering what
exactly is her strategy and really what
is Tyrion strategy that she's listening
to and specifically Lana doesn't want
her to listen to so we have the war room
scene but they do have these amazing
shots of her table where she's actually
planning out the war so we can really
clearly see what she's planning on there
and then maybe I'll show on the map a
little bit too I saw a replica very very
good replica of this at the game
experience experience at San Diego my
man with all the pieces at it and yeah
the whole map is know that's a cool way
pocket one I wish I'd be kicked out for
sure oh man but we'd be better friends
so you can see this is currently
Dragonstone and we have the Dragon Force
which obviously is her and her dragon
but we have a couple of other sigils
here that are new that were made just
for this so down on the far left we have
a horse it's facing down a little harder
to make out but that's representing her
dress rocky army in the middle here we
had the unsullied represented by their
helmet and this looks kind of hard to
make out but if you look at it closely
it's actually a boat being taken down by
a Kraken this is the iron fleet force
and they're all currently at Dragonstone
time of the scene but their plan is to
go down to Dorne using the iron fleet
which we saw that way they were going to
bring the Dornish forces back up to
King's Landing to help surround it and
then on the other side the Tyrell forces
which is why we don't think Elena was on
any of these shifts she's probably on
her way
Highgarden yeah to bring back the Tyrell
forces in order to lay siege upon King's
Landing we should be really clear about
that is just essentially block all the
exits and start that yeah and I think
that's a really weird strategy i'm
inchin yara and Elena here you're a
dragon be a dragon get your dragons in
there and just lay havoc problem with
that is that of course she does not want
to be the queen of ashes and if she
destroys all of King's Landing and all
the people in it it's just rubble and
it's not usable the stage takes a lot
longer but it doesn't mean that you get
a lot more in our prisoners and everyone
voluntarily leave the premise well and
so they in order to get this kind of
happy ending though they also have that
also secret part of their plans I don't
think that we can discount where they're
going to go to Casterly Rock they're
going to take that unsullied force and
they're going to wipe out the other
Lannister force which is going to
prevent them from being reinforcements
for King's Landing yeah so it actually
would be a faster siege than you might
expect because they're not necessarily
going to have to also be fighting other
battles in hang time now there's another
question that you guys asked and that
was what about her fleet though doesn't
she need that in order to do it and it's
yes the fleet was a major part of it but
we have to be really clear here we know
from last season that the ships were not
all the iron fleet Yara and Theon
definitely had their ships with them
these are the ships that are burning but
they already had other shifts that were
belonging to the Tyrell Martel's
and her ships that she had previously
gotten that she had the Dothraki on and
the unsullied on Daenerys still has a
Navy yeah yeah it's just not as big as
it was and these definitely were the
heavy hitters in it so it's a loss but
it's not over for any kind of naval
strategic placements right the next
question I want to tackle here is you
guys are asking okay sure that's a
strategy but is it a good strategy
so you don't like it I love a fan of it
well I understand why they're doing it
they've got a lot of numbers now like
this new joint ally happening here with
the Tyrells and the dawn
Dornish all that it's great I'm in the
mind of if you want the Iron Throne take
the Iron Throne you go anybody dragon I
think that's the way that everyone else
has done it and that's the way that
leads to people hating you but the only
other time where was an invasion very
similar to this one it actually went so
well and that's Aegon's conquest and 300
years ago right so I'm so real quickly
walk you through this just so you kind
of get what Aegon did and why I think
the similarities are brilliant
so a Don actually launched also from
Dragonstone in his invasion and he
instead of going all at once and you
know taking over well back then it was a
separate Kingdom but instead of just
going to this full Ford at each Kingdom
he instead split up his dragons we
talked about that last time into three
different directions one went up to the
Erie's take care of the errand one went
to the Stormlands with the Baratheon he
was he had a relation with the Baratheon
and they fought down there and then key
Aegon himself went with his dragon
balerion all the way across to the north
near the river lands to take out
Harrenhal which by the way was a
brand-new castle but an Isis castle a
while of Westeros and blaring just
melted it it's like immediately right
that but by doing that he showed this
insane force in three different
directions all I was you know what I
gonna have that Daenerys dozen hmm he
had Dragon Riders need people to ride
those dragons for him and she's the
Elijah Daenerys have them I think she
does who is going to ride the dragon I
think we're going to see a little
fairing on a dragon i there would be Jon
Snow another dragon he can't basically
put his legs though I'm Indian
she can't either you think she's like
traveling that dragon I'm battling it no
she's a 727 she's baby she's lucky that
we can see her on it now and your point
doesn't make sense in that the dragon
force being properly wielded was
essential for Aegon and even then he
wasn't able to take Dorne Dorne stayed
its own Kingdom all the other kings
switched to vassals but Dorne was able
to withstand even the dragon there are
ways to withstand that
force especially if you're not wielding
them properly but my favorite real quick
and it's just because I hope this exact
same thing happens from egg on Konquest
the earrings yeah back then weirdly it
also was run by a little Lordaeron right
child a boy and he also was
simple-minded and you know how they're
they have their way up there and that I
didn't penetrable fortress actually I
don't go all hard to get to it so they
don't have to worry yeah well it's
pretty easy to get a dragon up there so
they get up there and instead of like
killing everyone all they do is a gun
sister offers the little Lordaeron a
ride on the dragon so you want to go
over on this dragon yeah yeah well I did
so I thought I thought that's what I was
learning that history I thought it was
like and then the dragon Aiden no it
just they realize like you know what if
we if it's that easy for our little King
to be impressed there's no way we're
going to withstand any kind of attack or
anything I think it's a brilliant
strategy it led to a very happy ending
that's he came back and he formed King's
Landing around where he landed we got
all over the history in this episode
with valerian melted all the swords
together and made the iron throne that
started cold yeah and then a nun lived a
really long time yeah and people thought
you know what he's not a bad thing in
general those strategy-wise I think is
brilliant moving on to our white wolf
you guys had some questions about Jon
Snow what he's going to have going on so
the biggest question though is is he
going to make a pact with Daenerys
Targaryen yeah my Anna he doesn't want
to be king of the north
he's so reluctant in that position he
obviously knows that the biggest threat
of the White Walkers he's seen them
firsthand he knows what they're capable
of and he just needs numbers and he
needs an army he doesn't care about the
cold Game of Thrones and he's gonna fit
on the Iron Throne right not his deal at
all he doesn't perfectly that point is
why I think it's like yeah no [ __ ] let's
have an alliance here I don't want the
throne I just need your help until they
oh okay
yeah I'm worried about Daenerys at the
moment because she's like oh if you want
fairy that's absolutely great but you do
one thing wrong and I would burn you
alive and if I won't come down people
are trying to help you and I think that
Jon Snow might coming here going wow
this is so great I just need people
whatever whatever
no I know something this is going to be
so hardcore aggressive and he's like
well we're on the same team right be
like are we feed to the dragon dragons
tried to burn him he can't burn cause
his dog Aryan would he becomes a dragon
rider he rides back to the north
oh my god I'm such a good stick you
smell of fire knife but ice becomes fire
with the dragon water food shoots ice
because I have a connection and ghost
gets up there somehow ghost on a dragon
is better than carrying on dragon and
you know it well why don't you Syrian
right goes for Joseph right in the
dragon oh my god so will they make a [ __ ]
yeah I think so of course though you do
have the point she's never seen the
undead and they even finally said at
this episode that when you haven't seen
him you kind of are like yeah I believe
you but like not a threat that he's
happening right now right he kind of
brings us to our next question you guys
had should he specifically kneel we
brought up earlier that Tyrion very
smartly left that out of me a letter
because we also know how people react
when they're told you can come and you
have to kneel the contrast otago rien
right kind of my big super shell but I
should he kneel to her is that a good
idea and I'm gonna once again look back
at Aegon Concours actually and say yes
that's a great idea because poor and
Stark was the king of the north at that
time and you know what unified all he
saw all of that damage I was going on
and he just watched in the north was the
biggest part of the whole thing he
definitely had men he could have thought
but he just decided you know what I will
lose everything they will become ashes
yeah I'm gonna kneel and he's famously
known as the king who knelt and yet it
worked out great for him he got to stay
in charge of the north and again
everyone loved a god well I have
something Johnson I've got two people in
his ear right now it's Davos who's
saying if we do not join forces we will
die and they is the truth like we all
know that maybe he doesn't know it yet
Jon Snow doesn't know that yet but then
he's also got some fire and he's just
made sure that sunset is now raining a
temporary Queen of the north and she's
calling all the shots so if I think it
came Neil which I wanted to and she
finds out there's going to be hell
trouble there because she didn't sign
off on it and then not having any forms
of communication before he announces his
plan to the court to the people and
again
episode she has to fight him in public
in front of his man so I think she has
no desire to turn on John but she has
established that she thinks she might be
a better leader than him big time and I
think she's the kind of person
especially in this position with once
she has a taste of it she doesn't Lee
give it back so I think that she's going
to somehow figure something out
what could the one thing that keeps her
in power be the information that Jon
Snow is not in no way a stark buff it or
not and so therefore she is the only
true Stark
wrote and doesn't have to give it back
to someone who has kind of been away had
been in a fraud position his whole life
and you know who else would do anything
to hold on to their power Cersei
Lannister mmm yep and she's already
admitted that she's learning a lot from
her so was it a mistake to leave her
there no because the Starks need to
trust each other and that's the way it's
got to work will it necessarily work out
for the best that's not the same answer
but the biggest topic we got to cover
it's what you guys want to know the most
about is also about a spark but it's
what the heck was going on with Arya
Stark specifically in this moment
between her and I'm area and this is
something we've been waiting for for
ages the last time that they saw each
other she was basically throwing rocks
at night Ameria trying to get her away
to save her and which is why a lot of
people are like well I know one reason
why that Mary doesn't like you right now
you do Ross better thing yeah yeah no
amendments you can control but this
reunion with Nymeria we're gonna break
it down for you a little bit because you
guys are asking a couple different
things literally what's going on and
then what it could mean so you know she
does reunite with Nymeria and we think
that Nymeria does remember who are you
alright so a lot of comfort she got her
scent yeah I mean my puppy like knows if
I'd been in the room oh my gosh I was
gone for a week and Zeldin hasn't left
my side and right now so there's that
but when Aria asked her specifically to
come back with her Nymeria is straight
up choosing not to do it and that's
leaving Aria heartbroken yeah first but
the two of us have two different
interpretations about what is going on
here yeah and what it could mean do you
wanna go first no you guys
right I think you dismantle my argument
very much yes uncle very different
series here all right so I think you got
to remember first of all when she says
and I marry up that's not you she's
making a direct reference to her and
season 1 EPSA for cripples bastards and
broken things Ned Stark is talking to
her about how she could one day grow up
to be a lady and she could marry a lord
and how nice that sounds and she's like
that's not me so saying that - Nymeria
means that she gets it and I marry is
not one to go reunite with the family at
Winterfell she'd become her own wolf so
she has her own ways now and her own
personal goals and by the way that's why
she named her and I'm married that's who
she is
then Mary was originally a warrior queen
she led the royal our refugees to Dorne
like a thousand years ago she by the way
is an ancestor of Oberyn Martell but
like way before him and she was
essentially the founder of Dorne and
made it a unified realm under the
Martell rule and the big thing is
they're essentially running away from
the Valyrian at the time but she took it
upon herself you know what I have my own
mission for my people we're going to go
over here and I don't care what anybody
else is doing or what they're saying and
she literally when they landed she
burned her own bleak so that people
couldn't change their minds anymore like
I do my own thing that's my mariya the
warrior queen so I think she's totally
understanding oh right
we aren't that person we aren't the ones
that go back for jolly ol reunion we
have new life and new goal then she's
actually thinking what am i doing going
to Winterfell
that's not who I am anymore I'm not
going to go there and be a lady I'm
gonna go back down to King's Landing and
do what I said I was gonna do I'm gonna
try to kill Cersei Lannister that's
great I mean I love that you even
brought like pictures to support your
argument and you have backstory that's
so cool what you're talking about and I
marry a living up to who know more what
Ari named her let's talk about I is name
so I had gone to my mary saying it's me
oh yeah but guess what is spent all of
last season doing removing her name a
girl has no name and it's been twined in
magic here but she's essentially removed
herself from not owning being Iyer but a
stark altogether and I think by doing
that has made sure that those two things
this anymore you also notice that right
here no Miriah has a pack she's got a
pack of all her own rules she's been
running free with the pack and I'm areas
looking at Eyre who the lone wolf who
would buy herself she's seeing that
gnome area has her own pack she's back
with the walls back with the stacks and
that's involved where I am must go now
and then back to the north with her pack
the other walls the Starks so I have a
feeling after this she's going to keep
going to the north and reunite with her
family and no Miriah like ghosts will
always be there when they most need them
so you compelling argument so where's
are you going to go that's what we want
to know let us know that down in the
comment that's a big question of this
episode but let's move on out of our
questions to what you guys voted on the
rankings of who won Game of Thrones with
this week specifically yeah coming in at
third place is Daenerys Targaryen
yeah because we've seen the first part
of her plan in action and it hasn't gone
according to plan we've got 30 drawings
first blood in a war that is absolutely
impending and I think there's far too
many people in Danny's ear now is she
going to be the dragon is she going to
listen to Tyrion too much is happening
it's not clear which is why she's not in
a higher position I get it all only 11.6
percent of our audience voted for her
and you're right she's listening to
Tyrion about her strategy and she's even
questioning that with Elena so as a
leader
her influence feels a little watered
down also this week specifically her
fleet is also watered down yeah but but
that said she still got three dragons so
I don't know about her Beefalo but
coming in at number two yeah we've got
that a Lannister like I said she's using
propaganda as a weapon and that is an
effective thing to do especially in
King's Landing where pride amongst the
Lions not a great pun I didn't even mean
that one it was so good so she's getting
strength more and more she is expanding
her army and she's got one killer thing
that she hasn't seen coming yet you're
on
so 15.6 percent of the vote going to
Cersei and also not just that your
honors going to be joining her side but
the fact that she influences your on to
do what he has this episode finally
doing it for head no you clean does
really mean that she has a
on of influence if she caused the events
that you're on went on it did but that
doesn't matter because the number one
result is still your on grade row with
thirty nine point one percent of the
vote he is the one who won the game of
Thrones League but he also won our
separate designation a kill count he's
got the most kills to got the most blood
on his hands
big-time he's deadly we actually really
love the choreography in this but you
see his fighting style it's just so
caveman it's so blunt for it's those
drinks and it's very frightening because
he took down through sans name right you
know what I think is fascinating though
you may have won the week in terms of
kill count with eight but Yara Greyjoy
killed seven that's really good Dion
killed six when like these are all
people that really were much larger
threats than we thought of they were
keeping up with your on to that level
one of the sand snakes didn't kill
anyone she just thought I don't know it
was the other one oh really yeah yeah
yeah it's usually one of the tougher one
I'm speaking at onceá and she she just
bought your on and died pretty quickly
like these are these are the best
assassin yeah they say and I got like a
bit of dekappa dekap dick capitation in
there mmm I think that was an abyss oh
but you know exactly what I'm talking
about and then finally uh we're gonna
check out next week's teaser and then
we'll hit you on the other side with
some prediction hmm I was born to rule
the Seven Kingdoms and I will
we've already begun Agron first blood
first it will be ready they know we're
coming
that moment was sensational
I set up a TV at that we did we were
waiting this whole time even John saying
the name Daenerys wrong it's wrong but
it was him saying it and hearing
Daenerys say John's name this has always
been waiting for this entered the
patient I cheered when they talked about
meeting each other and then she said and
he will kneel and I come on No so it
looks actually like they didn't show
that much in that trailer no option
my guess is that's going to be casually
rock they said that they were going to
head there and that was the unsullied
that you saw them kind of breaking in
there okay so my prediction for next
week is going to be that that we're
going to see a battle of the unsullied
take on Casterly Rock and I'll go out on
a limb on the stage they're going to be
successful because they just had this
huge flow this episode I don't know way
wait that cosplay wrote I think that
everyone is for forces yeah ever since
Tywin died Catholics drink and like that
was just a minute it wasn't moment on if
you saw where Jamie looks like he's
walking through an archway that looks
similar to Kathleen you were randomly
there Oh that'd be huge
and what's your big prediction for
nightly and well we got a glimpse of
Melisandre talking to Daenerys for the
first time about the prophecy and saying
that both her and Jon Snow are playing a
pivotal role within you know the whole
survival of Westeros so who's going with
Jon Snow to meet Daenerys Targaryen
Jabba Javas is now hopefully maybe I
predict going to have a stern word with
my laundry in the form of a knife that's
right he did banish her he's like
obviously a tree guts and he said he
never wanted to see you again
and hey what you need are you doing here
does all right well that will be next
week and we'll cover it then too and
we'll answer your questions about that
episode that you're going to leave for
us with the hashtag Westeros weekly on
Twitter we look forward right after the
episode and also remember to vote in our
Power Rankings track in each week we'll
track it all season well the nice big
fun infographic at the end of the season
yeah and you love that you're excited
about that one anyway guys I'm at mode
Garrett and if you do want to subscribe
to my channel
put a bunch of stuff coming up from San
Diego comic-con so just search geek bomb
and get that subscribe if you can sweet
at me at fimo if you have any other
question
otherwise watch our breakdown we're
going to cover even more stuff I will
see you next time
hi
look back up here
let's see wrong gal boom you're an album
if I'm a Nelson is your